[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Abend ihnen allen es ist der
vierte Advent und wir haben einen
Fußball-Weltmeister
passend das in Argentinien Hochsommer
ist und sie draußen feiern können so
sieht Buenos Aires jetzt aus der
Prachtboulevard den zu überqueren man
schon an normalen Tagen mindestens zwei
Minuten braucht
heute ist kein normaler Tag sie hier
sind alle Weltmeister
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für die Menschen in Argentinien ist das
Meer als ein Fußballtitel es ist sowas
wie eine nationale Erlösung kurze
Ablenkung von der verheerenden
Wirtschaftslage und für einen der alles
erreicht hat der letzte Triumph der noch
fehlte
Argentinien Frankreich ein atemraubendes
Finale ein Fußballfest für die
Geschichtsbücher Michael Kreuz
es ist ein lang ersehnter Triumph für
Lionel Messi und für Argentinien der
Kapitän krönt seine fantastische
Karriere
ich bin glücklich für mich für meine
Mitstreiter für ganz Argentinien wir
sind Weltmeister
er hat zweifellos den größten Anteil an
diesem Erfolg es ist die 23 Minute zuvor
hat denn belee und Held die Maria zu
Fall gebracht Elfmeter Messi tritt an
und trifft 1:0 für Argentinien durch den
Superstar der mit seinem 26 WM Einsatz
neuer Rekordspieler ist
Argentinien deutlich überlegen
McAllister auf andrell die Maria das 2:0
die Marias tolle Stadt 11 come back nach
Verletzungspause
Frankreich auch nach dem Wechsel
unterlegen doch dann dieses Foul am
eingewechselten kolomani und erneut
Strafstoß
mbappé der Anschlusstreffer in der 80
Minute und nur eine Minute später
Doppelpass mbappé mit tyram und mbappé
unwiderstehlich zum Ausgleich 2 zu 2 der
Titelverteidiger erzwingt die
Verlängerung die 180 Minute Martines
Loris lässt prallen Messi und die
erneute Führung für Argentinien 3 zu 2
Messi schon am Ziel
nein Frankreich kommt zurück der Schuss
von mbappé Handspiel montiell Elfmeter
und kill young mbappé lässt sich auch
diese Chance nicht entgehen 3:3 mit
seinem achten WM-Treffer wird er
Torschützenkönig welch ein Spektakel das
Elfmeterschießen muss die Entscheidung
bringen nachdem Frankreich Kingsley
Coman nicht verwandeln kann trifft auch
zur Mini nicht die große Chance für
Argentinien ist da
Gonzalo montiell souverän 4:2 gewinnt
Argentinien das Elfmeterschießen ist zum
dritten Mal Weltmeister
ein Finale das seinesgleichen sucht und
Lionel Messi zum besten Spieler des
Turniers gewählt mit dem perfekten Ende
seines letzten WM-Spiels
das Mobilfunknetz in Buenos Aires ist
ein bisschen in die Knie gegangen in den
letzten Stunden das kann man verstehen
ich hoffe Christoph röckerath hört uns
trotzdem Christoph kann man die Stimmung
irgendwie beschreiben bei dir
[Musik]
also ich weiß nicht ob mich jetzt jemand
hören kann es ist ein bisschen chaotisch
leider das liegt daran dass unsere
live-position
also unsere live-position ist leider von
sehr euphorischen vertrieblichen aber
doktorischen Fans überrannt worden das
Handynetz ist auch zusammengebrochen so
dass ich jetzt etwas außer Atem bin weil
ich erstmal irgendwo hinlaufen musste wo
ein bisschen weniger los ist buenos das
kann man wirklich sagen dreht total
durch das ist ein wahnsinniges
holen wir haben Menschen gesehen die
während desselben Spiels weinen vor
Freude bei einem verschmerzen und das
beste war eigentlich das
beeindruckendste war eigentlich als dann
die Gegentore für Frankreich viel und
diese ganze Masse die die ganze Zeit am
Feiern und jubeln war als hätte
Argentinien schon gewonnen plötzlich
ganz still wurde die ganze Stadt diese
pulsierende Metropole war für einige
Momente absolut leise das habe ich so
noch nie erlebt natürlich Verantwortung
danach groß und jetzt öffnet mir
wirklich alle aus das ist natürlich so
dass Argentinien diese Weltmeisterschaft
zu einem Zeitpunkt gewinnt oder das Land
das kann man wirklich so sagen eine nein
kollektiven Depression was einfach daran
liegt dass diese Wirtschaftskrise
Argentinien wahnsinnig hart getroffen
hat dieses Jahr ist die Inflation noch
mal schlimmer geworden und jetzt ist
einfach so eine Erlösung viele haben uns
hier im Gespräch gesagt es ist toll dass
wir der Welt zeigen können dass wir für
irgendetwas doch noch Weltspitze sein
können dass alle sehen können wir
Argentina wir können kämpfen wir können
etwas und wir haben wirklich etwas
geschafft und in Zukunft noch die Person
von Lionel Messi natürlich messi ist ein
Held für Argentinien das ist nicht neu
aber eigentlich hat immer diese Helden
gerade im Fußball gehabt in diesem
völlig Fußball verrückten Land das war
lange die über Maradona den man sogar in
der Zeit dass er mit den ganzen
Skandalen für negativ Schlagzeilen
sorgte die Stange gehalten hat die Feuer
gehalten hat und
entsprechend super Spieler aber eben
auch der Unvollendete auf dieses Gefühl
des unvollendet Seins trifft eigentlich
bei vielen anderen Staat der so eine
Geschichte hat auf die Kinder sehr stolz
sind eben nie so diesen ganzen
sozusagen erreicht mit dieser
Wirtschaftskrise und der Bestand so ein
bisschen Messi letztes Messi der super
Fußballer tatsächlich auch noch
Weltmeister und entsprechend groß ist
auch darüber die Freude
Christoph vielen Dank das war eine
Live-Schalte die so viel besser gepasst
hat finde ich als wärst du auf der ganz
normalen Position der statischen
live-position wie sonst immer gewesen
herzlichen Dank nach Buenos Aires wir
haben die Stimmung mitbekommen ein
Hochsommertag ein hupender Hochsommertag
den dieses Land nie wieder vergessen
wird
hätten wir da auch sein können diese
Frage stellt sich Hansi Flick heute in
seinem ersten Interview nach dem Aus in
Katar aus deutscher Sicht war das eine
schwierige WM sportlich enttäuschend
politisch herausfordernd wirtschaftlich
mit folgen das kleine Emirat
Gaslieferant für große Teile der Welt
und die schlechte Lage der
Menschenrechte dort waren Thema
wichtiger Debatten bei uns hier im
Westen
Kata selbst sieht sich als Sieger des
Turniers will jetzt mit zusätzlichem
Selbstbewusstsein auftreten und für
weite Teile der arabischen Welt war es
die beste WM aller Zeiten goliatai
berichtet
es war so etwas wie der super Sonntag im
katarischen Kalender Finale und
Nationalfeiertag vor 144 Jahren führte
ein Vorfahre des heutigen Emils die
Beduinenstämme auf diesem Boden zusammen
die WM ein weiterer Meilenstein seine
Geschichte
die WM ist eine historische
Errungenschaft für Katha und die
arabischen Länder und dazu die gute
Gastfreundschaft und Infrastruktur wir
wollten allen Zuschauern unsere
Traditionen und Sitten zeigen das macht
uns stolz dass sie nun mehr wissen über
Katha über die Golf Länder
verzeihen Sie ich rede offen aber ihr
deutschen Medien habt doch ein falsches
Bild der arabischen Kultur vermittelt
dann kamen die Leute und sahen die
Realität
alles fing an mit Kontroverse und Kritik
das einzige mal als ein Symbol für
Toleranz in einem Stadion auftauchte war
nur von kurzer Dauer
dafür zelebrierten arabische Fans und
Teams ihre Liebe zu Palästina eine WM
der Widersprüche nicht nur wenn es um
politische Bekenntnisse ging
die Gastarbeiter im Industriegebiet auf
deren Rücken die Stadien und Katar
gebaut wurden durften wir nicht besuchen
in ihrer Fans ohne hier weder die FIFA
noch Kata kündigten Verbesserungen oder
umfassende Entschädigungen für Sie an
und wie war das mit den
Korruptionsvorwürfen den alten und den
neuen einen Tag vor Bekanntwerden der
Ermittlungen im fernen Brüssel ehrte
Emir Termin
anti-korruptionskämpfer aus aller Welt
mit einer eigenen Auszeichnung nach ihm
benannt
[Applaus]
Ermittlungen hin oder her viele Fans
schwärmten von familienfreundlichen
spielen ohne Hooligans dank der Metro
konnten sie gleich mehrere Spiele am Tag
besuchen wo gibt es das schon
die Kulisse und die Lichter bezauberten
und viele konnten sogar dem Mangel an
Alkohol im Land etwas abgewinnen
mir gefällt mir gefallen die Menschen
mir gefällt das Ambiente der Atmosphäre
ich für mich ja gut und sicher ja ist
einfach toll hier ich sag mal das was in
Deutschland viel erzählt wird
es ist hier nicht so definitiv so und
wie gesagt wenn wir wieder zurück sind
wenn wir nur Positives mitnehmen das
WM-Finale ist nicht das Ende sagen uns
die Katara nein dass er hier erst der
Anfang
10 Jahresvertrag mit der Formel 1
abgeschlossen es gibt die Schwimm-WM
2024 die tischten 20 25 die Asienspiele
20 30 nächstes Jahr schon die Fußball
Asienmeisterschaft also Sport wird ein
zentrales Politik Instrument für cater
bleiben
für fifa-Chef Infantino war es wie er
sagte die beste WM der Geschichte aber
die sportlichen Glanzmomente konnten
nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen dass sie
für viele die umstrittenste WM aller
Zeiten gibt
Collie Katha ist plötzlich in aller
Munde was bleibt von dieser WM gehen wir
es doch vielleicht gemeinsam mal durch
heute abend all die Missstände die
angeprangert wurden wie wird es da
weitergehen wird dieser hat dieser
internationale Druck irgendetwas
erreicht auch langfristig
nein das kann ich bis jetzt nicht
erkennen also Cutter wird Cutter bleiben
Menschenrechtsorganisationen haben ja
schon eine negative menschenrechtsbilanz
gezogen es sind keine neuen
Selbstverpflichtungen jetzt hier
verkündet worden von Seiten der FIFA von
Seiten der katarischen Behörden und als
hier vor kurzem ein Arbeiter
tragischerweise verunglückt ist in einem
der WM Stadien da hat der katarische
Chef des WM Organisationskomitee ist
einfach nur lapidar gesagt der Tod ist
denn natürlicher Bestandteil des Lebens
auch innenpolitisch wird sich hier
nichts verändern zumindest haben wir bis
jetzt keine Ankündigungen dazu
mitbekommen ich gehe nicht davon aus
dass ich hier die Auffassung der
Religion verändern wird des Lebensgefühl
verändern wird Kater ist im Vergleich zu
den anderen Golf Monarchien doch eher
eine konservative oder konservativere
Gesellschaften man hat globale
Ambitionen aber man lebt und denkt gerne
Lokal und bleibt unter sich und ich
denke das wird auch so bleiben und dann
Golly nee auch im korruptions-skandal
der ja gerade das Europäische Parlament
erschüttert es ist im Beitrag ganz kurz
angeklungen da soll ja Katar eine
unrühmliche Rolle gespielt haben zieht
sich jetzt aber offenbar nicht kleinlaut
zurück sondern droht ganz unverhohlen
ja das sind ganz andere Töne erstmals
heute eine Reaktion der Katara darauf
dass war vor einigen Monaten noch ganz
anders da waren die Europäer ganz stolz
die erste EU Repräsentanz hier und Doha
eröffnet zu haben und heute plötzlich
das diese Töne von Seiten der katare es
heißt die Beschuldigungen der EU sein
selektiv sie sein Bestandteil einer
unrühmlichen Medienkampagne gegen Katha
die schon seit Monaten so gehe die
ganzen Beschuldigungen sein Vorurteils
beladen gegenüber katata und dann holt
man die ganz große Keule raus und sagt
das ganze können natürlich auch dazu
führen dass man die Gespräche zur
Sicherheit Zusammenarbeit mit Europa
einstelle das ganze könne dazu führen
dass man Gespräche zur Energiesicherheit
Europas einstelle also es bestätigt
wieder einmal die Konklusion der
vergangenen Tage dass Beziehungen zum
Westen zwar hier in den Golf Ländern
erwünscht sind aber das
es ein großes Selbstbewusstsein gibt und
dass das Selbstbewusstsein durch die WM
einfach noch mal gestärkt worden ist und
dass man sagt Beziehung in die Arbeit
nicht zu jedem Preis und dann lass uns
doch ganz kurz über die Folgen reden die
diese WM für das Verhältnis Deutschland
Katar hatte Katha ist ja auch für uns
soll ja auch für uns wichtiger
Gaslieferant sein
ja es gab massive Verstimmungen in den
vergangenen vier Wochen und es wurde
zumindest hier positiv angemerkt dass
Kanzler Scholz vor zehn Tagen sich
gemeldet hat beim Emir bei Emir Termin
und laut katarischen Medien ihm
gratuliert habe zu Ausrichtung und zu
Organisation der WM dass man gemeinsam
noch einmal die Beziehungen
durchgegangen sei und nach
Verbesserungspotenzialen gesucht hätte
so zumindest katarische Medien von
deutscher Seite heißt das nur dass es
ein Telefonat gegeben habe aber immerhin
das wurde über Deutschland hier positiv
angemerkt Kollege herzlichen Dank für
diese Berichterstattung live aus Doha
heute Abend von der WM nach dieser WM
und jetzt in der Sendung etwas aus der
Reihe klingt kompliziert werden wir aber
alle spüren es muss uns also
interessieren worauf sich die
Europäische Union danach Verhandlungen
die Nacht hindurch jetzt gar nicht hat
es ist das wichtigste Klimaschutzpaket
der EU und das steht jetzt vor einer
bahnbrechenden Reform wer in Europa
klimaschädliches CO2 ausstößt muss
künftig häufiger und mehr dafür bezahlen
das betrifft Unternehmen und uns
Verbraucher die Details hat aus Brüssel
die Dächer rings um das Europa-Parlament
mäßig isoliert bei -6 Grad das Bild vom
weißen Rauch war wohl nie passender die
Augenringe waren selten dunkler es ist
der Sonntagmorgen nach einem
Verhandlungsmarathon wir haben das
größte klimagesetzes Paket beschlossen
was es auf der EU jemals gab und wir
mussten hart dafür kämpfen dass der
Klimaschutz nicht geschliffen worden ist
das heißt wir werden also diese 55 %
weniger CO2 im Jahr 20 30 erreichen es
ist 2 Uhr nachts als einer sein Handy
zückt alle EU-Institutionen sagen ja
damit ist das Gesetz so gut wie durch
drei Jahre sind vergangen seit die
kommissionspräsidentin kaum im Amt einen
Ansporn setzte Klimaneutralität bis 2050
heute beginnt nur eine Reise aber dies
ist Europas Mann auf dem mondmoment man
on the moon Moment
die Gesetzesarbeit dazu war profaner ein
csringen bis heute fit vor fifty five
bereit für den großen Schritt beim
Klimaschutz der hohe Anspruch steckt im
Namen des Gesetzes EU-Kommission Rat und
Parlament wollen dafür
62% der Verschmutzungsrechte
schrittweise aus dem Handel nehmen und
kostenlose Rechte auf Null reduzieren
das treibt den CO2-Preis das Spüren mit
der Ausweitung des Emissionshandels auch
Hausbesitzer und Autofahrer 45 € pro
Tonne CO2 das macht pro Liter Diesel 10
cm mehr das greift erst in fünf Jahren
das ist eine Belastung aber nicht für
Deutschland so Abgeordnete dort sei die
Ausweitung schon gesetzt die EU ziehen
nur nach da haben wir einen riesen
Schritt gemacht heute Nacht das ist
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit für
deutsche Unternehmen gibt und faire
Behandlung für alle in Europa
nicht die deutschen zahlen und die
anderen nicht sondern wir machen das
gemeinsam darum steht im Gesetz auch ein
Fond für klimainvestitionen mit 86,7
Milliarden Euro ist gedacht für die
Ärmsten der arme er wird aber nicht
ansatzweise ausreichen um die
energetische Modernisierung des Gebäude
Bestandes umzusetzen und wird deswegen
eine Bedrohung des Wohlstandes in Europa
sein das Konto schonen und das
klimaschützen dieser Anspruch wäre wohl
noch größer als das Gesetz
und was heute auch noch wichtig ist hast
du im Blick Hannah die
Nachrichtenübersicht an diesem Sonntag
ja wegen massiver Probleme mit dem
hochmodernen Schütz
enteidigungsministerin Lambrecht morgen
mit Verantwortlichen der Bundeswehr zu
einer Krisensitzung treffen bei einer
Schießübung waren alle 18 Beteiligten
Panzer ausgefallen das berichtete der
SPIEGEL der Generalinspektor der
Bundeswehr Zorn erklärte es werde alles
für eine schnelle Wiederherstellung der
Einsatzbereitschaft der Puma getan diese
sollten eigentlich ab Januar für die
schnelle Eingreiftruppe der NATO
eingesetzt werden
bei der
weltnaturschutzkonferenz in Kanada liegt
kurz vor dem offiziellen Ende ein erster
Entwurf für eine Abschlusserklärung auf
dem Tisch der Vorschlag enthält auch
eines der Hauptziele mindestens 30
Prozent der weltweiten Land und
Meeresflächen sollen bis 2030 unter
Schutz gestellt werden zudem soll es
mehr Geld für den Artenschutz geben
Kritiker bezeichnen den Entwurf
allerdings als zu wage beobachter gehen
nicht von einer schnellen Einigung aus
wegen der aktuellen medikamentenmangel
hat der Präsident der Bundesärztekammer
Reinhardt gesunde Menschen dazu
aufgerufen vorrätige Arzneien an Kranke
abzugeben es bräuchte so etwas wie
Flohmärkte für Medikamente in der
Nachbarschaft sagte er dem Tagesspiegel
Engpässe gibt es aktuell unter anderem
bei fiebersäften für Kinder aber auch
Krebsmedikamente und Antibiotika sind
laut Gesundheitsministerium betroffen
nordkorea hat erneut potenziell
atomwaffenfähige Raketen getestet nach
Angaben Südkoreas und Japans starteten
zwei ballistische Mittelstreckenraketen
an der Westküste Nordkoreas diese seien
dann in Richtung des japanischen Meers
geflogen bevor sie ins Wasser stürzten
seit Beginn des Jahres unternahmen
Nordkorea nach unangaben mehr als 60
Raketentests so viele wie noch nie in
einem Jahr
in Großbritannien sollen jetzt Soldaten
die Krankenwagen fahren und an der
Grenze die Pässe kontrollieren denn die
die das sonst tun haben genug Energie
und Lebensmittel werden rasant teurer
immer mehr Menschen treibt das in die
Armut das Land erlebt die heftigste
Streikwelle seit Jahrzehnten
zehntausende Beschäftigte sind es bei
der Bahn bis zu 100.000 in den
hospitalern es ist ein abgekämpftes
Königreich die ersten sprechen von
Broken Britain aus London berichtet
Andreas Stamm
typische Straßenszenen Großbritannien im
Dezember Streikposten
Eisenbahner Postler Lehrer weite Teile
des öffentlichen Dienstes streiken den
Überblick behalten wer wann wieder die
Arbeit niederlegt ist in
Nachrichtenredaktionen eine Kunst für
Grafiker geworden sogar das
Pflegepersonal sagt es reicht der erste
Ausstand seit 106 Jahren der staatliche
Gesundheitsdienst NHL s sei kaputt
gespart worden und attraktiv als Job
10.000 Stellen nicht besetzt 7 Millionen
Patienten warten auf notwendige
Behandlungen Daniel arbeitet seit sechs
Jahren auf Station und steht hinter der
Forderung nach 19% mehr lohnen viele
schmeißen den Job hin weil es zu wenig
Geld zum Leben ist dann können sie sich
nicht so um Patienten kümmern wie sie
gerne würden weil es an Personal fehlt
und dann der Stress zu Hause weil es
nicht reicht für die Rechnungen und um
die Familie zu versorgen
wie überall im öffentlichen Dienst hat
auch das Pflegepersonal seit 2010 real
weniger Geld ein Minus von 12 Prozent
was das heißt zeigt sich im
frauenkrankenhaus Birmingham jeder
siebte Mitarbeiter in der Pflege 10.000
beim landesweit größten Arbeitgeber
nutzen Essen Spenden doch nicht nur
Schwestern greifen zu bei Lebensmitteln
gespendet von besser verdienen
niemand sollte hungrig auf die Arbeit
kommen schon gar nicht vor einer zwölf
Stunden Schicht und es sind nicht nur
das Reinigungspersonal oder die Pförtner
es kommen röntgentechniker Schwestern
Hebammen zu uns weil sie damit Probleme
haben es seien immer mehr Vollzeit
beschäftigte die zur Tafeln müssen
schlagen Gewerkschaften Alarm auch
Lehrer oder Polizisten kämen teils nicht
mehr über die Runden
wir leiden daran dass unsere Wirtschaft
seit 15 Jahren kaum wächst es fing
damals mit der Finanzkrise an die alle
traf aber wie auch die Pandemie hat es
uns härter getroffen als vergleichbare
Länder dazu der brexit der die Sache
weiter verschlimmert die stark
steigenden Energiepreise sind Gift für
Britannien da wir mit Gas nicht nur sehr
viel heizen sondern auch sehr viel für
die Stromerzeugung brauchen
die Energiekrise hat die Inflation auf
11% getrieben 5 Millionen Menschen
müssen sich Umfragen zu Folge an manchen
Tagen entscheiden ob sie Geld fürs
Heizen oder Essen ausgeben
Ende Oktober premier kämpft noch gegen
die Hinterlassenschaft seiner
Vorgängerin die wollte in der Krise
Steuern senken die Finanzmärkte verloren
das Vertrauen Millionen Hauseigentümer
bezahlen das nun mit höheren Zinsen bei
einem Krankenhausbesuch erklärt er
jüngst er werde wegen der Streiks hart
bleiben die Staatskasse leer höchstens
5% mehr lohnen sonst drohen noch mehr
Inflation
verhärten langfristig für noch mehr
Personalmangel sorgen am Ende muss die
Regierung im öffentlichen Dienst Löhne
wie in der Privatwirtschaft zahlen sonst
wird niemand als Lehrer oder Pfleger
Arbeiten
1 verbindet Regierung und streikende
nichts wird besser nur immer schlimmer
erklärt Krankenschwester Daniel das Land
ist dabei in eine lange Phase
wirtschaftlicher Stagnation zu rutschen
als ein kranker Mann Europas
alle Briten die über Weihnachten ins
Ausland wollten und auch alle Besucher
die planten zu kommen warnt die
Innenministerin jetzt keine gute Idee
bleiben sie besser zu Hause
bei uns hier noch mal Hanna und zwar mit
Sport beim zweier Bob Weltcup im
US-amerikanischen Lake Placid sind zwei
deutsche bob-pilotinnen aufs Podium
Gefahren Laura Nolte die am Samstag den
ersten deutschen Sieg im monobob
weltcupu geholt hatte wurde Zweite und
Kim kalicki fuhr auf Platz 3 der Sieg
ging an die Gesamtweltcup führende Kelly
Humphries aus den USA
zum Abschluss der Kurzbahn WM im
australischen Melbourne gab es heute
eine zweite Medaille für die deutschen
Schwimmer Marius Schulte Bronze über 100
Meter Schmetterling hinter dem
Südafrikaner Jetlag Klo und
Ilja Kyron aus Kanada
das jüdische Lichterfest hanuka hat
heute begonnen es erinnert an den
Wiederaufbau des Jerusalemer Tempels vor
2200 Jahren acht Tage dauert das Fest
und jeden Tag entzünden die Gläubigen
ein weiteres Licht des hanuka Leuchters
als Zeichen für Versöhnung und Frieden
so auch in Bremerhaven dort wurde der
erste öffentliche fest installierte
hanuka Leuchter Deutschlands
dann schauen wir jetzt traditionell an
einem Sonntagabend auf das was uns
kommende Woche erwartet hier ist der
heute schon mal Ausblick von Dominik
Lessmeister
[Musik]
am Mittwoch wird das Urteil im Prozess
gegen den inzwischen abgewählten
Frankfurter Oberbürgermeister Feldmann
erwartet dem SPD-Politiker wird
vorteilsname vorgeworfen hintergrund ist
eine Affäre um überhöhte Gehälter bei
der Arbeiterwohlfahrt
ebenfalls am Mittwoch wird den
Washington der Abschlussbericht zum
Sturm auf das Kapitol erwartet dabei
geht es auch um die Frage ob der
Untersuchungsausschuss strafrechtlicher
Ermittlungen gegen Ex-Präsident Trump
empfehlen wird hunderte radikale
trump-anhänger hatten am 6 Januar 2021
den Sitz des Kongresses gestürmt
zum Auftakt der Weihnachtsfeiertage
findet am Samstag die traditionelle
weihnachtsprozession von Jerusalem nach
Bethlehem statt Papst franziskus wird
dann Heiligabend in Rom die Christmette
feiern
so in der unmittelbare Ausblick beim
Wetter sieht leider nicht besonders
ermutigend aus wir müssen da ganz
dringend drauf gucken weil Sie wissen
sollten was sie morgen früh beim
Aufwachen erwartet guten Abend Katja
honnefa aus unserem wetterteam was kommt
denn meteorologisch auf uns zu ja gar
nicht erst morgen früh sondern schon
heute Nacht es liegt daran dass die
Temperaturen total niedrig sind aktuell
haben wir zum Teil Temperaturen bis
minus 10 Grad und der Boden ist einfach
durchgefroren 20 30 cm ist die
Frosttiefe und jetzt kommt von Westen
Regen heran es hat schon ein bisschen
geregnet erstmal nur so vor einzelten
Rheinland-Pfalz und den Hessen massiv
aber bereits in Nordrhein-Westfalen und
dieser Regen sieht bis morgen früh
weiter ostwärts wird also etwa so bis 8
Uhr hamburg erreicht haben auch
Sachsen-Anhalt und Thüringen wir müssen
uns jetzt also in der Nacht und bis
morgen früh in diesem großen Gebiet auf
extremes Glatteis einstellen und der
Glatteis Regen sieht dann morgen über
Tag auch noch weiter auswärts wird also
zum Beispiel auch Berlin in den
Vormittagsstunden dann erreichen genauso
wie Dresden und Rügen danach allerdings
wird es deutlich milder ist es mit dem
Glatteisregen vorbei und das zeigen dann
auch die Temperaturen dann haben wir in
Westdeutschland Temperaturen von 8 bis
11 Grad morgen das geht also dann ganz
schnell aber erst kommt das böse
Erwachen was hat denn das konkrete für
konkrete Folgen jetzt also ungefähr
sechs bis zwölf Stunden lang müssen wir
damit rechnen dass es diesen
Glatteisregen gibt und das bedeutet
instantan wenn der Regen auf den
gefrorenen Boden fällt wird das eine
spiegelglatte Fläche das heißt der
gesamte Verkehr wird zum Teil zum Liegen
kommen also sowohl auf den Straßen wie
natürlich auch auf den Schienen
Flugverkehr alles wird beeinträchtigt
sein und deswegen kann ich wirklich nur
sie warnen wenn es draußen regnet und es
so eiskalt ist gehen sie besser nicht
raus
das war eine Warnung eine Ansage Katja
vielen Dank wir haben es gehört und wir
wissen jetzt was uns erwartet und damit
schicken wir sie in diese Nacht morgen
sind hier Marietta Slomka und Heinz Wolf
für Sie da und wir alle hier sagen im
Namen des gesamten Teams auch dem hinter
den Kulissen herzlichen Dank für Ihr
Interesse und gegen 0.30 gibt es hier
die nächsten Nachrichten
[Musik]